so it turns out a lot of you guys are
pretty injured
after i posted my video on building
stronger knees i was inundated with
requests for similar videos
tackling ankles shoulders hips and just
about everything else
but for now i'm covering elbow pain this
is a subject close to my heart because i
have struggled with elbow pain
myself on and off multiple times and
it's something that a lot of people deal
with on a regular basis
and there's good reason for this not
only because a lot of the movements we
use in the gym in fact
the vast majority of them put a lot of
pressure on the elbows
but also because a lot of things we do
in our daily lives actually exacerbates
this issue
just like it often does for things like
shoulder issues hip mobility problems
we're just piling dysfunctional
dysfunction the good news is that by
just making a couple of small tweaks to
your training adding a couple of small
exercises into your regime you can
actually undo a lot of this damage
and build much stronger tendons that are
going to be perfect for climbing ropes
performing cool calisthenics moves and
even things like
deadlifts which likewise can put a lot
of pressure on the biceps
and on this tendons and as a nice added
bonus this can also lead to much
bigger bicep and if that sounds good
then on with the weird curls
before we start to strengthen our elbows
let's first look at what can go wrong
with them in the first place and why
they're often so weak to begin with
tennis elbow or lateral epicondylitis is
pain felt on the outside of the elbows
and is the result of repetitive
movements such as curling or playing
tennis
or hyperextension during movements like
punching you'll notice you also
experience this pain when performing
gripping
extension and twisting supination
movements with the hand
and wrist supination meaning that you're
turning the palm upwards towards the
ceiling
this can affect several extensors most
prominently the carpi radialis brevis
and the rest of the common extensor
tendons golfer's elbow conversely is
pain felt on the inside of the elbow at
the medial epicondyle a bony protrusion
on the inside of the humerus
you'll feel this during flexing and
pronation any tendon that inserts at the
medial epicondyle
can be the cause here including the
pronated terrors flexor carpi radialis
etc
golfer's elbow is commonly caused by
golf hence the name but it can also be
caused by a number of throwing movements
and by climbing
it's also sometimes called climber's
elbow for this reason and it's actually
also very common
among manual laborers finally you might
experience pain in the biceps muscles
themselves or in the distal biceps
tendon that connects the bicep to the
radius
it's also possible though much less
common to experience injuries affecting
the triceps and triceps tendons
just to strengthen the ankle can prevent
any complaints strengthening the wrists
and shoulders can help to avoid elbow
injuries
the wrist is probably the prime
candidate for many people here
this is because several tendons span
both the elbow and the wrist joint
for example the extensor carpi radialis
brevis originates at the humerus
the lateral epicondyle and inserts at
the posterior base of the third
metacarpal
the base of the middle finger on the
back so pain in the elbows is often
actually the result of a weak wrist or
forearm
this may partly explain my own bad luck
seeing as i broke my wrist into pieces
when i was 13
pretending to be jackie chan nearly
every exercise you perform with free
weights
is also a grip exercise specifically
you'll be using the flexers in order to
close your hand around the bar
but this also creates activation in the
extensors
very often the antagonist muscles work
as stabilizers for the prime movers
in this case the extensors come online
to prevent the wrist from fully flexing
this creates imbalance the extensors
become overly fatigued without being
directly strengthened in the way that
flexors so often are
so it's no wonder that they can become
tired and then injured either that or
your poor overworked flexers
simply give up making matters worse is
our lifestyles as usual
if you use a mouse or keyboard then
you're constantly flexing your wrists
and fingers and doing very little
extension
if you do this all day then go and lift
weights you've just increased your
chances of injury
a lack of mobility in the wrists can
also be an issue as tightness makes
injury more likely
when falling onto both hands a simple
fix or preventative measure is to train
your wrist extensors and flexors
you can do this with both pronated and
supinated wrist curls
pronated wrist curls are best for tennis
elbow while supinated are useful for
golfer's elbow but you should always do
both
balance is key
you can also buy devices that provide
their own resistance to use
check out my all new toolkit page on the
bioneer.com which i'll link to in the
description down below
here you can find the one i use and
links to all of the different things
that i use in my videos and all the
services and gadgets that i recommend
and a really simple exercise you can use
to combat this to an extent
is just a pronated grip on a barbell
curl or dumbbell curls
so just take the weight now you're gonna
use an overhand grip
and cut it like so and now what you're
doing
is you're fighting the weight that's
trying to force your wrist into flexion
so now you're maintaining an isometric
hold
in the forearm extensors
strengthening them and hopefully
preventing that imbalance that affects
so many people
one of my favorite exercises for
building biceps and stronger elbows is
the biceps curl with supination
start with the palms facing inward and
then twist them upwards as you curl
the biceps are responsible for not only
elbow flexion but also shoulder flexion
and supination of the forearm
supination means turning the palm
upwards which means you're training two
different functions of the biceps at
once
hammer curls are great too these are
curls using a neutral grip with the
palms facing inward
they focus more on the long head of the
biceps located on the lateral that's
exterior side of the biceps
it also hits the brachialis
brachioradialis and pronated terrors
the good news is that this can add
significantly to your bicep size
if you're using only supinated curls and
will help create bulging forearms too
finally hammer curls can be excellent to
strengthen the elbows ready for rope
climbing
another exercise that's very tough on
this joint a more straightforward injury
is the old biceps or biceps tendon tear
this can be caused by overdoing it on
bicep curls chin-ups or deadlifts
which also means it can happen when just
lifting anything heavy
so planche training is actually one of
the best tools you can use to strengthen
that tendon
but of course we're not just going to
jump into planche training instead we're
going to use progressions like the
pseudo planche push-up
this is a push-up performed with the
hands further back around waist level
and the upper body position forwards to
create a slight lean your hands will be
turned outwards or even behind and
you're going to push up from there as
you normally would
but make sure to fully straighten and
lock out the elbows at the top of the
movement
to work your straight arm strength this
is where all that pressure is going to
be placed on the biceps tendons
you should also push through the ground
with your arms straight thereby
protracting the scapula
if you want to build up the planche this
is a must but anyone can benefit from
this exercise it builds injury-proof
biceps
that are especially useful for those
that do lots of deadlifts
you can also strengthen your biceps with
high volume bicep curls
obviously using higher volume will help
to get lots of blood flow into the area
and if you use continuous time and
attention this may encourage
capillarization
meaning you can actually create new
blood vessels feeding the biceps and
tendons
this is very important as the tenders
receive less blood flow compared with
muscles
making them slower to grow and recover
and more prone to injuries
eccentrics are also fantastic for
strengthening tendons
this means slowing down and focusing on
the lengthening or lowering portion of
the movement
get help lifting a barbell into position
and then very slowly let it lower again
alternatively you can try jumping up to
a pull-up bar and then lowering yourself
slowly
in a chin-up position in one study it
was found that using eccentric heel dips
could treat chronic achilles
tendinopathy more so than simple
rest in nsaids at the other end of the
arm of course we also should be
strengthening the shoulders
this will aid with stabilization to
prevent unnecessary torque and
impact on the elbows when throwing and
performing other movements
i'll talk more about shoulder mobility
and stability in my shoulder video
but strengthening the scapula with
scapular push-ups and scapular pull-ups
can help here or you can get the same
benefits with scapular protraction and
retraction during other exercises
like the aforementioned pseudo-planche
push-ups you can also train the rotator
cuffs with a variety of exercises
like the prone external rotation or
lawnmower row
or the classic forward lateral and rear
dumbbell raises or one of my favorites
for shoulder stability and mobility
the gamma cast which can equally be
swapped out for kettlebell halos
or bulgarian bags spins start light oh
and i also love the weight to plate
steering wheel
hold a weight plate in front of you like
a forward raise with both hands then
twist it left and right
like you're pretending to drive a car
it's funny just how many videos and
articles that focus on building elbow
strength and resilience
entirely talk about the biceps
forgetting that obviously the elbow
moves in two directions
so the triceps also on the back have a
big role to play
strengthening the opposing muscle the
antagonist
can be a great way to prevent injury in
any range of motion
and this is something that once again
the needs over toes guy talks about he's
not
all about knees obviously some
activities do involve
kicking the elbow backwards and as
antagonistic muscles
they also have a stabilization role to
play whenever you're doing a curl
or anything else the antagonist muscle
always activates to a certain extent to
try and keep the
joints steady so you really want to
strengthen these to prevent those
injuries and in fact your musculature in
your arms should be more like two-thirds
tricep
one-third bicep so you should actually
be doing a lot more stuff
for your triceps than a lot of people do
especially if you're isolating the
biceps through a ton of movements
i don't want to get too general here as
this post is about stronger elbows
but of course proper nutrition is
crucial as is generally using varied
regular movement
doing hundreds of curls with a single
grip and movement pattern without ever
switching up
is of course going to lead to imbalances
and overuse injuries
this is obvious when we really stop and
think about it variation will create
balance
and another way to do this is by
climbing trees or even climbing around
the pull-up bar which naturally forces
you to change your position
and your grip this is again why i
believe in varying and mixing up your
training
the body likes variable movement it was
never designed to stick to one rigid
range of motion
using man-made tools over-use injuries
aren't really about doing something too
much
it's about doing something so much more
than anything else you do
joints are designed to last a lifetime
obviously i'm not suggesting that if you
have a bad elbow you should suddenly
start
lifting lots of heavy weight at weird
angles that's only going to exacerbate
the issue
the point is to strengthen slowly to
use progressive overload to strengthen
those weak areas those weaker tendons
and smaller muscles
and we can do this first by using very
light
weights and higher repetitions slow
controlled movements
and then building up to heavier weights
as you get more confident you can use
easier progressions etc
listen to your body ease into it and
always check with the doctor as i said
in my knees video anything could be
wrong with you you could have an
infection you could have a stress
fracture
so don't guess the issue and then try
and fix it this is more just a way to
fortify your elbows
and some exercises you can try to
strengthen them and speed up your
recovery
with the go ahead from someone who's
actually checks you over in person
and consider that we're all different as
i've mentioned before i recently had my
dna analyzed by self-decode
i learned among other things that i have
a tendency towards tendon and muscle
injuries
attend on c this is partly due to a
variation in a gene called sod
2 which helps to alleviate oxidative
damage
and inflammation by producing an enzyme
called superoxide
dismutase my homozygous a genotype
is correlated with lower sd production
and higher muscle inflammation markers
the wellness report i received from
self-decode suggested that i could
combat this with h2 supplementation
seeing as some studies show that this
can actually raise sod levels
i'm trying that right now and i'll let
you know how i get on if you'd like to
try out self-decode and have your own
dna analyzed and you can actually find a
link to that in the description down
below
i actually get some commission on that
so if you make an order it'll support
the site in a big way
but the point is not to say that you
should take hydrogen although maybe
rather the point is that we are all
different and different things work for
different people
and you may in fact be more or less
prone to tendon and bicep injuries
don't beat yourself up if it happens to
you it's part of the training journey
and finally don't give up on those
persistent pains and injuries
the answer is out there somewhere you
might just not have found it yet
and hopefully some of these tips will
work for you
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that would help me out immensely let me
know in the comments down below if
you've ever experienced elbow pain
how you fixed it or whether you're still
working towards a fix right now
subscribe of course if you want more
content like this and hit the bell
button to be notified of new videos
as i upload them if you're looking for a
training program that combines multiple
different training modalities to help
avoid injury and improve performance
across the board then you might be
interested in my ebook and training
program
super functional training i'll put a
link to that in the description down
below
there's a discount on right now whilst
we're dealing with a pandemic
alternatively you could try my print
book functional training and beyond
this is an introduction and a broad
overview of functional training as a
topic
if you want to learn more about how to
make the most out of your body and what
functional training means for the
average person
then you should check that out as well
and i'll likewise leave a link in the
description down below
that's now available on audible as well
and the short supply in europe and the
uk
has seemingly been fixed thanks so much
for all your support on that by the way
the positive reviews are
much appreciated the reaction has been
overwhelming and i'm very grateful
as i am for your continued support of
the channel for your comments and for
watching these videos
it's all amazing so yeah thanks so much
and i'll see you next time
bye for now